hey how you doing Greg so sometimes it's
a little hobby I'd like to watch street
fight compilations I specifically like
the fights where it's like there's a
bully and the bully gets taken down cuz
he didn't realize that he was bullying
some kickass [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] with certain people man
anyway I got sent this video a long time
ago and I should have just going through
some old Facebook messages and I was
like I watch this because I I sometimes
look I'll be up late at night sometimes
just watching like these brutal fights
going now from the best fights channel
knew best street fighting KO compilation
2016 15 highlights here we go peeps
nice nice very good Kenny very good
oh [ __ ]
god I wish I knew how to trash talk damn
that dude zoom like a really fight he's
boning like a boxer man this guy it he's
clearly dodging like one oh [ __ ] dude
you know go up against the boxer you
said the n-word whoa oh no oh no oh no
oh [ __ ] hey mean uh I don't feel better
watch you he's special of I get one oh
my god dude you do not like that person
oh she's going down on this [ __ ]
whoa whoa whoa
no this is not good guys oh [ __ ]
just a fight good fight these are like
real fighters the guy has that one right
punch damn dude yeah what all right no
no I was looking cool he just kicks him
away look away oh oh
down down
what's gonna happen why is it being so
mean I don't know
oh wow whoa [ __ ] I all you guys it's a
joke
wow dude oh no no no oh always taking up
a [ __ ]
I never my fat kids got back it's the
wait nevermind
ah I just will you beat me
good hit whoa punch a solid hook man
well why are they mad at each other
uppercut love is reaction whoa whoa do
you feel like a sidekick to that guy oh
there's gonna be real yeah mmm nevermind
only one of them's a real fighter boy
really except ship systems history but
they budget
Oh
oh damn
you just stop you honor him - well you
like jumped up in the air not cool not
cool
oh hey guys I wanna be much done [ __ ]
you get yeah I love that
oh [ __ ] oh you shouldn't have punished
them you violent not in tune with all my
positive thinking
Oh No that woman like bleeding kind of
moment
so sad oh [ __ ] yeah awesome
oh nice he tried stripping it all we
worked there you gonna out serious you
took off your shirt you better win well
that was that was a nice thing a federal
in there damn oh yeah business come down
no [ __ ] no environment plays a big part
in the effect of these videos oh [ __ ]
that
Oh mister I'm sorry oh [ __ ] yeah smack
you
Wow I don't know what it is man like I I
grew up on a kung fu cinema like the
Jackie Chan gently saml home you and be
out days when they were really uprising
and others like now everyone's into like
Tony John Donnie Yen and they're [ __ ]
awesome but that's the time when I was
like really invested in Mike Hong Kong
cinema I also grew up doing martial arts
I did martial arts for about eight years
and I can still kick and punch and [ __ ]
you know if I practiced for a little
while five I don't know man there's just
there's something about I was once
talking with this man who was uh he was
father had like several children he was
a hard-working dad I really respected
this guy he had a business but on the
side when he worked out you would box
and you know he really talked to me a
lot about an eye creed with the ability
to fight of how important that could
sometimes be in a man in a man I say
that so confidently in a man Oh be
honest the years of sparring the years
of I I think I've been in like one or
two actual fights before I was twelve
than that I haven't really been in a
fight
no way one time not in really I didn't
throw fists or anything there was a
fight broke out at this party a guy was
hitting my friends so I grabbed him and
I throw him in the pool and I think I
was like eight no 17 yeah still wasn't
even an adult anyway though yeah I mean
sometimes I just prepared and I just
never benefited more but I I like to
watch these because it's like you never
know you know craziest ones are when
someone like picks a fight and then they
and I'm getting their ass owned because
and no idea the other guy get really
like has fighting skills as practice
fighting or something cuz you could tell
whenever some guy is just a violent dude
throwing his fist around and you can
tell when there's a guy who like
actually has like legit some type of
martial art boxing experience you know
anyway blast watching I don't know I
think these are so fun new to the
channel you can subscribe today reject
subscription services are so much fun oh
my god we mainly talk about movies but
every once in a while I do a video like
this that's what we called the real
rejects facts